uh first of all welcome everyone uh to
this uh very important uh demonstration
which can definitely help you for
proceeding ahead and uh getting
certified in one of the very hot
technology in the market called as
Salesforce my name is Shaker and uh
I'm professional Salesforce trainer and
uh associated with simply learn and uh
I'm very much honored to give some kind
of important guidelines to you all on
this topic related to Salesforce
certification so we are done with the
introduction it's time to proceed for
the
session so first of all we are going to
see what we are actually going to plan
here please note that the agenda that we
are going to have in today's session is
this first of all we will see overview
of Salesforce if anyone is new having no
idea about Salesforce he will get
definitely some good understanding about
Salesforce
here next we are going to learn
importance of certified people in the
market a very important thing for anyone
who is looking for a very bright career
option for next 15 approximate years how
I'll tell you about that very shortly
next types of certification and details
in
Salesforce I'm going to tell you one
very important thing a master plan for
Preparation how you can prepare in
Salesforce certification which can give
you guaranteed success is a very
important thing for planning in a quick
time in whatever time you have in your
hand and get the result successfully and
finally or you can say the last but one
option experience
of all the past candidates previously
how they prepared how they did we are
going to understand their planning and
you know very well when we understand
how these successful people plan and
executed their preparation it will be
one of the very important thing for you
to understand and get the confidence and
finally the chance for you to get
clarified with any pending questions
that you have that is Q&A so I'm going
to proceed with the first
thing overview of
Salesforce so please note Salesforce is
now having no uh Salesforce is now uh no
there's no need need of giving any kind
of introduction for Salesforce because
now it's one of the very very
top company in the market the
brand has made huge change in the IT
world as well as it is growing High year
by year with all successful
releases but still some small
information or overview about Salesforce
that will help everyone to get the idea
and be on the same page if anyone is is
there in this session knew about the
Salesforce idea first of all Salesforce
started all the journey as a CRM tool in
the market where the focus was giving
the Solutions in CRM domain CRM means
customer relationship
management but you know very well that
before 10 15 years like when Google
started it was just a small
small garage uh small company settled in
the garage with only one Focus that
giving a easy search facility to the
internet user but now Google is
everywhere it's in Mobile you have the
operating system you have the
browser you have the car you have the
glasses you have social social
networking site plenty of things are
there Google is almost
everywhere CM case with Salesforce
Salesforce started with CRM tool only
one goal that is to provide CRM
Solutions but now Salesforce is
everywhere it's in marketing it's in
shipping it's in finance it's in
healthcare it's in sales it's in
Hospitality it's in education it's in uh
you can say Hospital domains Healthcare
domains sales Salesforce is growing like
anything now that's the reason now
Salesforce will be in upcoming years
considered to be synonym for business
applications that's the main reason why
people are changing their career and
coming to Salesforce because they know
that there will be plenty of
opportunities here onwards because
Salesforce is growing if Salesforce is
everywhere we get huge possibility of
getting job and demand in the
Market the domain where it's used just
seen now it's going high and also
Limitless in terms of domain initially
only one domain CRM but now it's almost
everywhere in future we are going to see
in
Salesforce spreading in variable devices
Internet of Things various mobile
applications various uncovered business
domains and this way Salesforce will be
one of the very important element in the
market that is the reason many big
companies are putting lots of money in
Salesforce because they know that this
is a very ke key player and the market
changer there are plenty of big Brands
Now using Salesforce they are trusting
Salesforce and they are now un they have
understood that if they go with sales
force progress they are indirectly going
to get the benefit in their business
model and that's the reason
they are using Salesforce heavily for
example Google for example Facebook for
example eBay for example G for example
Phillips for example Coca-Cola plenty of
big Brands relying on
Salesforce so this is something about
introduction to Salesforce or what
Salesforce is in the market now we'll
understand something very interesting
which will be very much useful for you
because ultimately you guys are here and
you guys are having plan to make your to
build a bright career in the it domain
importance of certified people in the
market now this is very interesting
point see many people realize or or they
are aware of only 50% of the
truth and they are not clear with the
remaining other other sign of the other
side of the coin that is the 50%
remaining
fact they don't know or they don't
realize
that just learning
Salesforce is not going to give any kind
of
solution in terms of the job placements
or possibility the main thing is if you
are certified or not so they focus only
on this and ultimately they don't
realize that why they are not getting
the success or so much demand the way
they heard somewhere or they knew by
some other sources so the other side of
the coin is if you are certified then
only you'll get this 100% benefit but
the question is why certified people are
important in the market let me tell you
something about that first of all when
any Market is hot when we have when we
have so much demand for any product in
the Market ultimately we know very well
that there will be hundreds of
candidates coming towards that domain
now Salesforce is so much successful
that all new people are planning to come
toward Salesforce they are planning to
come and have a career on Salesforce and
this way now we have so many people in
the market who knows Salesforce or
they're looking for Salesforce as a
career option when we have thousands of
people please note the competition will
be also very very high and that is the
reason we need to understand now how can
we bypass this competition please note
it's a very important point for you to
understand how to bypass this
competition because ultimately you want
to secure those kind of opportunities
where which can change your career okay
so let's try to understand something
about
that when we have thousands of
candidates for any single position
please note how actually the market
works or resume filtering process work
which is very important for you whenever
in the market any position is open and
they're looking for any kind of
candidates with Salesforce experience
first thing that they will see is
whether the person is certified or not
because that is the first and important
criteria that they follow if you are
certified then they will proceed with
that if you're not certified then they
will not consider all those resumés
which are of non-certified candidates so
that is the first criteria if you're
certified chances of selection is more
for the interview call I have seen
plenty of companies because I have
worked with various HR people as well as
the recruitment firms to understand how
they plan please note always remember
one important thing the policy they
follow is if any person is not sertified
please note they simply avoid those
resumés and they don't entertain that
resume and this way you'll not even
understand why I'm not getting any kind
of interview calls that is a very
important point you should understand
that is the reason that is the reason we
always Focus or we always emphasis on
getting certification and that's the
reason we need to understand this
important factor okay
now not only this resume
preparation not only this resume
preparation goes for this kind of
certification priority but also clients
have some specific requirement for
example I have seen plenty of
clients I have seen plenty of clients
who actually
use the formula or you can say one
important concept they say to the vendor
tell me how many certified people you
have not only tell me how many certified
people you have but also send me their
certification soft copy and guys please
note this is the reason now companies
are very serious to select only that
person who is certified because
ultimately client is not not going to
give you project if the people are not
certified again another important thing
so now you might have understood that if
you are well knowledgeable on Salesforce
you have done so many training you have
learned so many aspects but if you are
not certified then one drawback you are
not going to be fil you're not going to
be filtered in a resume PR resume
selection process so companies will not
call you second the companies will not
select you either because ultimately
clients will reject you so that is the
reason those people who are certified
they get double benefit and they get
maximum calls as compared to uncer not
certified people
next now this is very important for us
salary estimation ultimately we always
Focus to have a very strong salary or
good salary as compared to the market
system here please note if you are a
certified person and you don't want to
change the company you want to continue
with your same company still here you
are going to get good increment or hike
if you present yourself as a certified
salesource people so many examples I
have seen where the candidate is not
interested to change the company he
wants to continue but he's expecting
some kind of consideration in the annual
increment process you know you know that
generally people have in the month of
April or in the month of January the
annual increment process and they can
demand specific hike or expect some kind
of hike by their
managers
so here we can simply expect and add any
kind of information we can expect any
kind of valuation or you can say go for
this process if you are certified you
can expect and present yourself and tell
what kind of progress you have made in
terms of Salesforce process and finally
you can get the needed hike as well on
the other side if you're changing the
company then if you are certified you
can present yourself with this knowledge
that you have with the help of
certifications and also demand good hike
or salary so there are multiple
Dimensions by which a certified person
gets benefit and this is the these are
all the important things of CER
certified people and that's the reason
certified people are highly appreciated
in the IT
world
now after understanding the
importance or multiple benefits of a
certified person in the
market let's see if we have a plan to
get certified what kind of ways what
kind of options we have in the
market this is
next slide types of certification and
details a very important thing because
when you know your path well then you
can have a successful
Journey please note there is long list
of certification uh categories in
Salesforce ultimately our focus should
be what is in
demand there are more than 10 types of
certifications which you can do in
Salesforce but our focus should be what
Market needs and that is the reason I
have mentioned here all those important
certifications that you can
focus and then I return so on because
remaining certifications even if you
bypass as of now at the beginning of
your career absolutely fine only focus
on these names which I'm mentioning and
you can expect some kind of
good you can say growth in your career
remaining things these are optional if
you do latter words that's also no
problem now let's see one by one the
types of certifications that we have the
most important the beginning level
certification which is called as
administrator or 2011 the number it's
having a very popular number 2011 or you
can also say Salesforce
administrator this is the step first or
you can say the primary level
certification which will be expected by
any person who is just starting their
career in Salesforce or who wants to
have a strong idea about fundamentals of
Salesforce so many people who want to
start their career they should go for
administrator here you will get complete
idea about Salesforce ecosystem how it
works structure models all the
fundamental things which can be a strong
pillar for your Salesforce
career now here we have plenty of people
already in the market you'll see there
are so many people having the
certification and when we want to stand
something different or you want to
present something special as compared to
them so many people now go for some
other certifications after
this next more popular one is app
builder because it is very new it is a
latest certification so many people go
for that what it
contains app builder is more focused on
covering the latest features that
Salesforce is giving to you for example
working on apps mobile
lightning the automation process
Builder flows Etc so ultimately you will
be having Advan F and latest knowledge
in Salesforce domain so that is the
reason many people perform this
certification and then they can go for
this certification the person having
combination of these two certifications
definitely get good demand in the market
because this being a new exam it came
recently and very so that is the reason
many few people are there in the market
who are certified in app builder and
that's the reason person certified with
app builder gets good chance of
placement suppose you have done with
these both and you want to increase your
knowledge more or you want to present
yourself as a more knowledgeable person
then you can definitely go for a
platform developer or this consultant
stream but the question is whether we
should go for both or anyone I would say
only one as of now because if you are a
person having no interest in programming
you don't want to involve in a
programmatical approach or coding and
all these things then please note this
is not for you then what you can do go
for this go for this and if you want to
do specialization in terms of sales
business or service business then you
can go for
that suppose you are very much
interested in doing programming as well
then complete this complete this and
then go for this which will test your
skills of
programming but if you see or if you
observed no matter whatever Branch you
going to select the foundation is 2011
and app builder and that is the reason
in simply learns standard Salesforce
syllabus that we have our focus is
making candidate certified on
administrator and app
builder now there is one very
interesting confusion I have seen in the
market see recent before few months
there was a
concept 2011 certified people 41
certified people but recently Salesforce
made some change in the exam pattern
which made huge blender or you can say
brought some kind of big confusion in
thousands of people I have seen whenever
I see some kind of question or any kind
of article or any kind of blog there are
so many
people who are confused and asking the
questions related to the recent change
which Salesforce made today you are
going to get a good Clarity on that so
you will be completely clear what this
change
is Salesforce was having 20 401
format now in this format you for you
were you are actually having the same
format of current 2011 previously it was
same but after that to test your Advan
knowledge without any programming we
used to have
401 Salesforce now cancel this exam
instead of that we have a very similar
exam which is called as app builder so
anyone who heard something about
2011 as a first
step then 41 as a second ladder please
note instead of 401 now you can simply
go for app builder so it will be a
similar scenario okay so please note now
there is nothing like 4 in the market
there is AB Builder Okay so this is a
very important point you should be
knowing now let me go for next slide
which will be helping you to understand
how you need to prepare for this
examination a very important slide
because ultimately you are going to get
a good knowledge out of this and you can
now start preparing for
your uh start preparing for the
examination now please note first of all
there are various Master
plans which
actually you can say uh uh which you can
find on internet which says that
guaranteed success plan of sales force
certification or the very important
steps you need to follow for preparing
and plenty of questions believe me I
have seen many such people who have
tried this scenario But ultimately I
have seen they are getting no such
success the reason is these things
doesn't
work let me tell you example of one of
my colleague please note he was having
good experience in Salesforce almost I I
can say 2 three years then he tried to
go for an examination of
Salesforce he thought that some kind of
resources which he got on the internet
will be easy for him
ultimately he
failed and when I tried to understand
what was the matter please note that the
information what he got on the internet
some kind of questions he got on the
internet all were completely not correct
and ultimately he got failure he lost
his $200 and also demotivated because of
that failure and please note that thing
you should always avoid because all the
suggestions which you see on internet
not sure they should work today we are
going to understand all those important
steps which are tested proven and 100%
success guarantee is going to give you
100% success guarantee let's talk about
that first of
all the common mistake which people do
they directly jump on some kind of
sample questions or any easy resource by
which they can get the benefit or
shortcut please note there is no such
shortcut if you try to go for that
shortcut definitely there is big risk of
getting
failed please note some standard steps
are there if you follow that and then
you try to go go for those kind of
sample questions and all then we can
understand that but when people directly
go for those sample questions and follow
the wrong path they simply see the
failure okay so now we are going to see
all those important steps all those
important things that you need to follow
let's see one by
one point number one there are specific
Salesforce
documentation if you go to the
website and you go for any kind of
certification information
then please note there are some specific
exam guide which tells which give you
complete information what is the
syllabus many people bypass that very
important point and start preparing
please note when you don't know what is
the preparation Point how you need to
prepare then your preparation will be
completely misguided so first understand
what Salesforce says to you
understand the complete
syllabus then you need to go for next
step now we are very much clear about
Salesforce expectations or the content
of syllabus now second question which
will come in your mind this syllabus
looks very big there are so many points
and yes guys of course there are so many
points so many uh you can say topics per
exam and you will not understand how
should I proceed because one one single
topic may take five 10 or sometimes 15
days for you to get the good
Clarity and that is the reason from that
ocean of syllabus you should get the
gist and understand what all those
points are there where you need to
focus if you do this believe me within
15 to 20 days sometimes in even 10 days
you can very well prepare the
examination then that important aspect
you should understand that a trainer or
an experienced person can tell you where
you should focus out of all this ocean
of syllabus
next once you're ready to proceed
understand how much time frame you have
I have seen many people that they don't
make a plan they say okay I have 20 days
to plan my manager is saying I have 20
days to plan and they simply go for the
preparation they spend 5 10 days and
ultimately when they
have when they have just four five days
in hand they realize they have literally
lost so much time and then finally they
get the failure please note we need to
prepare topic by topic plan and that is
one of the success factor
here if you have 20 days in your hand
divide all those topics which you see in
20 different days and then prepare every
topic day by day ultimately keep one or
two days of buffer time for Preparation
believe me this approach helped plenty
of people who were completely new to
Salesforce had few days in hand but
ultimately they found success in the
certification next
now another very common mistake people
do
they read so many notes so many
questions plenty of resources and when
they go for the examination because they
think if the examination is objective
type there is nothing to write nothing
to do only select the option out of four
options one correct option is there or
two correct option click it done then
they think or they have misconception
that it doesn't need to do any kind of
activity just read the books read the
notes read the sample questions and go
for the examination no that will not
work because if you are having good
Hands-On idea of any particular topic
then only you will be at the position to
give the answer please note this is a
very important factor you will
realize once you will be in the middle
of the exam not getting anything not
able to answer anything and then
realizing oh I did a very big mistake by
not doing handson so guys please don't
do this mistake try to go for maximum
handson
next after doing this all activity your
success also realize how much clear you
are in terms of the business perspective
what is the meaning of that for example
let me make a let me give a simple
example there is one very popular
popular Topic in Salesforce called as
workflow rules it's a very popular topic
I believe many people from this session
already knew this topic or they're
having the idea workflow rules now just
understanding workflow rule or writing
or reading two four pages of workflow
rule going for exam is not
enough if you understood the business
scenario when to use workflow rule when
not to use workflow rule
then only you will be able to understand
the scenario based question please note
guys out of all the 60 Questions in
Salesforce exam you have almost 70 to
80% questions are scenario based those
people who believe that reading
remembering and going for the exam is
the success uh success rule please note
for them it's a very big trap because if
if you don't understand the concept you
don't understand business aspect you
will not be able to give this 70 to 80%
questions because sales force exams are
scenario based more and less in terms of
straightforward
answer and that is the reason always
focus on understanding business
perspective as well another
important point for getting success and
finally some dos and don'ts this will
this you'll get the idea by any
experienced person or the person having
a very good idea how Salesforce exams to
be delivered successfully for
example we know very well that in
Salesforce
examination we have SIMPLE technique
simple format we have one
question and we have one option two
option three option four option and we
need to select something from this as a
correct answer that we everyone knows
but there are some important tricks that
you need to follow that I'm going to
tell you right
now see one important tck trick here is
when you are not clear on the answer of
any particular question there is one
very proven and tested trick go with the
negative approach what is the meaning of
that whenever any question is there and
you completely are blank you don't know
that what is the
answer then instead of leaving the hopes
try to implement this trick it worked
plenty of time to my previous
students first of all try to go with a
negative approach you don't know the
answer okay try to identify those
options which could not be answered
definitely that is go with the negative
approach so out of this four options
note those options which will be
definitely not the
answer so right now what is the
probability you have four questions that
is probability of passing is
25% 100 by 100 divid divided by 4 means
25% so 25% is the probability that you
are going to give the correct answer but
if I go with this approach for example
if I realize that question number one
and question number two they are not
definitely the answer okay okay so I'm
going to remove this I'm going to remove
this from my list now you are very much
sure that answer will be from option
third or fourth what is the probability
of getting pass the probability is 50%
this is a very useful trick now believe
me your probability of getting pass
passed is more and definitely if you
think clearly or you try to get the
answer by thinking the or reading the
question again or by thinking Again by
different angles the chances of passing
gets more and all those questions which
you are going to leave assuming that I
cannot give the answer now you get the
50% more success as compared to that a
very useful trick very proven
trick such kind of Dos or don'ts are
there which also you need to focus by
getting the idea from a person who is
very much clear with the perspective of
this exam pattern one idea I told told
you I'm going to tell you one more idea
which you can take benefit
of please note another dos and don'ts
which will definitely help you is never
waste your time if you're not clear on
that
question I have seen some common
mistakes people are doing Suppose there
is a question that is question number 30
and you're you are you realize that I'm
not able to answer this
question immediately bypass this
question and go for
31 this looks a very small process but
believe me this is going to help you a
lot why because what is our common
tendency I'm not getting this question
30 you'll feel tensed now you'll feel
again one more time okay let me do one
thing let me read again okay not getting
let me do one thing let me try the
options
let me read the question again and this
way you will waste your 3 to four
minutes on the single question
ultimately going for wrong answers
instead of that bypass this question and
go non-stop giving all those answers
where you're confident and reach the
number
60 then there is one important benefit
for you or a very useful entity for you
or you can say um facility for for you
which many people don't know and they do
the mistake and finally they realize oh
I wasted my so much time I'm telling you
right now here before you go for exam
understanding this technique is very
useful for you this will definitely save
your 10 to 20% of time in your exam
you'll get additional Time by that what
is that please note at the end of the 60
question there will be one new
page which will tell you all all those
questions which you have
left you have not answered and finally
you can again come back to those
questions which you have not answered
one by one one by one question by
question you can give the answer to
those questions ultimately your time
will be saved because your time will be
invested in those questions where you
are very much sure this thing people
don't realize and after spending so much
time after wasting so much time and when
the question exam will be finished when
they reach 60th question then they will
see on the screen that important
information and they will say oh I
wasted my time because I didn't know
that there is something like this after
60th question where I can even easily
see all those questions I left and I can
directly jump to that question to solve
that so Guys these are some important
dos and don'ts which will definitely
help you in your exam and make more
chances for you to get
passed now it says that experience is
the best thing to learn or come to some
kind of
conclusion I'm going to tell you some
kind of experiences of my previous
students who whose who shared some kind
of uh information about their s uh
preparation method or what best thing
they have found which help them for the
examination these all points are going
to help you which can be also the
driving factor for your
success please note at simp these are
all
students who learn by this platform of
Simply
learn they said that the content or the
learning content which you provide at
simply learn which is provided in their
LMS we have a separate section for each
and every student where we have some
learning contents which gave them so
much benefit that they have found almost
70 to 80% questions coming out of that
content if they have read thoroughly
they can very easily cover 70 to 80%
question next all those realtime
scenarios which you get or you you you
see confusing in the examination it's
because you're not having the practice
on understanding or solving real-time
scenarios here at simply learns learning
agenda we regularly have or go through
realtime examples topic by topic or
scenarios topic by topic students
automatically get the advantage and
practice that how to solve these
real-time scenarios or issues this
Advantage they get in the
examination
next as I said already that there are so
many mock questions or exams you'll see
on Internet please note many answers are
there which are
misleading you are going to get so many
wrong answer there and this way if you
rely on them please note chances of
getting fail is high and that is the
reason we have provided some very
good previous previously seen as well as
verified answered content questions as a
mock test available for all students so
in the LMS only you will see some kind
of mock test which has been
verified tested and also some questions
from them there are going to be key
questions in the examination as well so
these mock test help various students
handson here at simply learn whatever
course we have the focus is always on
Hands-On each and every topic whatever
possible we have to show or represent or
teach by handson we definitely do that
and this way students are very much
clear because they do also assignments
on that finally students are regularly
in touch of experts who guide them for
preparation of certification they convey
the dos and don'ts all those mistakes
which people do possibly in the
examination and this way this all
factors help all my previous students
ultimately getting 100% success please
note from my last five years when I
started focusing on exam preparation or
certification
preparation for Salesforce exams not a
single student ever failed till today
from last five five years the success
rate has been 100%
always because the candidates who follow
this path ultimately gets the
benefit so these are all important
points which you guys can definitely
take the benefit of and finally secure
your success and get certified on
multiple certifications and have a very
strong resume to get a very good job in
the market now it's your turn you all
have good opportunity now to ask me
questions any doubts you have related to
examination preparation process please
take this Advantage because I'm very
much interested to help you guys for
having a good career path ahead everyone
please
proceed
yeah sure uh man uh first of first point
which I said in terms of dos and don'ts
I said that
always go for next question whenever you
think that the current question which is
not clear to you or you are not able to
answer the question for example you in
the exam you are at question number 10
you think you're not able to answer this
immediately skip that question and go to
next question this way you need to
finish all 60 Questions then you'll see
a screen which will tell you all those
questions which you never attempted come
back again and give the answers okay
this was the important point and second
one I said go with the negative approach
if you think you are not able to
identify the correct answer okay then
first remove all those options which you
think they are definitely not the
answers and then your probability of
getting passed will be more these are
both these two things help my plenty of
previous B students and they got more
probability of passing I hope man you're
very much clear with this point okay
manprit I hope you're very much Clear uh
let me see next question uh okay please
type your question here in the chat box
so definitely can I can answer you so
this there is a chat box which you can
uh proceed
with
yeah sure now there is a question uh let
me go for that about the exam structure
and number of questions and passing
percentage now see I will go with the uh
I will go with this uh very popular two
exam patterns that we have that is 2011
in in the agenda of Simply learn 2011
and 401 that is uh what is new name app
builder okay so now let me tell you
something about that
first of all 2011 that is Salesforce
admin Salesforce admin is having the
number of questions that will be
60 passing percentage
65 that is you should solve 65% of
questions and those should be correct
the time is 90
minutes second is the app
builder 60 Questions passing score 60
3% time 90 minutes I hope you got the
answer of the question to understand
exam structure and number of questions
passing percentage and time provided let
me go for next
question now there is a question by um
Ashwin I hope you got the answer okay so
please let me know if you're clear next
is by S let me
see uh yeah sure sojna the technical
team or the concern team will definitely
do the
needful okay so please note uh uh Debbie
that uh Debbie is asking about the
Hands-On question please note that here
each and every person will be provided a
separate or and when the assignment will
be
done in the class or you can say the
Practical you've done in the class you
will be getting the questions for or you
can say assignments for doing after the
class and the trainer will evaluate by
various different ways whether you're
going right or wrong and this way he
will guide you so this way we go for
multiple level of approach ultimately to
ensure that candidate is getting
Hands-On knowledge on all those topics
which are necessary for exam Deb I hope
you got the answer shal is
asking that she is planning to go for
admin 2011 by end of August and app
builder in September okay so sha Al if
we focus on the first hurdle that is
2011 you have one month please note
start reading there are approximately if
you divide roughly there are 20 topics
approximately in 2011 Big topics try to
complete one topic every
day and this way try to finish
everything in 20 days remaining 10
days you can go
for if you're already enrolled with
simply learn then remaining 10 days you
can go for some mock questions mock
exams as well as scenarios mentioned in
your LMS definitely you'll get the
guarantee or you'll get the confidence
of getting passed same approach for app
builder one month enough for you I hope
you got the answer sha
Al next is okay is asking where can I
find more scenario based question okay
so please note that in LMS after every
topic we have scenario based questions
these are very special questions which
will give you good idea about various
scenario concept so you can get there
next
is serjan is asking do we need to learn
lightning experience in exam actually uh
if you see the ab Builder because in
2011 not needed in AB Builder there is
slight information about the lightning
experience which will be let's say
hardly two question or three question so
don't need to go into the more details
of lightning experience just to
understand process
Builder um something related to the app
something related to the app builder
okay this is enough so not needed to go
for complete lightning experience okay
so s this way you can invest your time
in the needed things I hope you are
clear next
is by
Ashwin uh let me read the question guys
and then I will answer there's a break
up of admin build topics and the
weightage is there a breakup of admin
and app builder regarding the topics and
the vitage of each Topic in the sales
sfdc yes Ashwin so if you go to the
website of Salesforce certification.
salesforce.com you'll get one
PDF which will be syllabus of admin and
app builder which will tell you all the
topics which will be in that exam okay
so please try with
that uh let me see next
question so just give one minute
uh let me just give that link to you so
where you can uh understand
the topics that will be coming for the
admin and developer examination just
give one
second so one is for admin and another
is for app
builder so guys
uh
the material or the document which can
help you for getting the information
about the administration okay so you can
go
for this one for
administration and uh for app
builder you can go
for this study
guide so this is for app builder study
guide you can take the benefit of and uh
for
administer you have this study guide
please note study guide is mostly not so
easy to understand because uh there are
plenty of things which will be confusing
for you but here at simply learn we make
the things very much clear and explain
each and everything for the candidate so
that they can get the actual Clarity and
how to prepare the things okay so I hope
you are clear now going for next
question there are plenty of questions
so let me answer one by one quickly
because we are running out of the time
um
app builder means developer 401 yes so
you can say so yes you can say so next
question uh I recently took the test and
there uh okay uh so okay please note
that we are talking about which exam
okay we are talking about which exam can
you please tell me you're talking about
which
exam uh next is in the certification
exam okay there is a question by Derek
in the certification exam do we need to
perform any kind of Hands-On in the exam
okay so direct please note it's
completely objective based no Hands-On
just selecting one answer or two answer
out of multiple options next is
uh admin exam you're giving on 14th
August okay Jamin uh so good luck for
that and please prepare well for that as
per the taking guidance and benefit of
this information that I shared today
next is
uh yeah so sha Al uh I think you're
already enrolled into the uh simply Lars
learning so the reference material you
will be getting in terms of the syllabus
in the LMS okay next next by Dona let me
see
that uh yes Dona you are very much
correct in the app uh in the app builder
you will have some kind of topics like
mobile process Builder workflow which
will be there because it's covering some
kind of automation
and advanced topics as compared to 2011
you are very much correct next question
by J okay J is informing about exam
date uh so s uh you might be having the
account at simply learn by that is
called as LMS account there we have some
mock questions they are very much
useful next question uh thank you
uh thank good to know that ashin that uh
you are clarified and welcome
okay no problem Dona and uh okay so okay
you have given the two1
examination you are given 20
examination okay when you give the exam
can you please tell
me yeah so please note please note yes
the recent change has been done into
that yes that's correct because if you
have given the exam recently then you
will see there the modified version okay
so guys please note if you have if you
are giving the exam recently or if you
are going to give the exam recently then
you'll see five more questions coming
the passing percentage 65 is same okay
but now here you'll find more five
questions into that as compared to any
previous scenarios which you might have
seen okay please note for now admin
you'll be facing five additional
questions in the new pattern okay but
the timing or the passing percentage if
you see in that it's same and please
note when you go for the app builder
when you're planning for app builder
examination now please note in that app
builder examination the total number of
questions that you're going to have in
the app builder examination please note
again we need to understand one more
important thing for the app builder
examination the total number number of
questions that will be same 60 and the
passing percentage will be 63 so very
small change has been done in the admin
of five questions okay so this is not so
important uh thing for anyone who is
already done with admin anyone planning
for admin just understand Small Change
five additional questions so you need to
be slight more fast I hope you are clear
now okay with the point and the new
number of exams questions which is only
in
admin uh so J if you're getting almost
70% in the mock questions then please
note you can assume that you are very
much close to 50 to 55% in the main
examination maximum okay because there
are plenty of new things which will
coming in the examinations but I will
say 50 to 55% secure from your
side uh let me see new
questions there is a question uh by SJ
do we need to prepare for intermediate
admin trial too for the exam if you do
that sjna that's well and good that will
give you
Advantage there is one more good
question by Ashwin which will definitely
help other people he is asking do we get
the result as soon as we finish the exam
yes ashmin immediately within few
seconds it will tell you pass or fail
but it will never tell you how much
percentage it will never tell you what
wrong answers you give okay so I hope
you are clear next one more question
bashin any written part in the exam or
is it all objective okay one more good
question completely objective nothing to
write okay nothing to write nothing to
implement no Hands-On just click on the
correct
option okay there is one more question
by okay let me
see
now there is a question by okay that
suppose someone that's also going to be
very helpful for other people please
listen guys what he asked it's a good
question he's saying suppose we we
performed or prepared very well by the
mock questions where the passing chances
will be 50 to 50% how to cover the
remaining Gap the remaining Gap you need
to cover by reading the thoro LMS
reading the thoro scenarios and
Performing the handson that way you can
fill the Gap I hope okay you are clear
with that and that's a good question you
asked people got more clarity by
that welcome okay so guys we
are uh we have extended our time by 4
minutes and I hope guys each and every
person got some good Clarity and good
understanding about this plan of this
examination that you're going to have
and I I hope I wish a very good luck
best of luck for everyone for all future
plans that you are going to have I
believe that my today's session gave you
some good idea and plan which ready in
your mind by which you'll definitely get
passed so my name is Shaker I a trainer
one of the trainer here at simply Lear
let's meet somewhere in future if you're
going to join any batch I will be there
to help you and give you more in detail
guidance if you came across at any point
of time that's all from this demon
demonstration thank you for your time
and patience we are done with that thank
you